slavery was our worst idea I'm not sure
I'd put prohibition second but it's
really up there I am Nicholas P with
reason TV and today we're talking with
Ken Burns the documentary filmmaker
whose latest project is out it's about
prohibition Ken thanks for talking to
Reason TV my pleasure
why is prohibition invoked these days it
seems between your documentary Dan
Okrent book from 2010 there seems to be
a real interest in this period and
reexamining it III think there's always
a superficial interest in prohibition
you know you've got gangsters everybody
wants to be able to kill the people who
pissed them off you've got women who are
seemingly promiscuous the you know the
flapper dancing with the short skirt and
the bobbed hair on top of the tables but
I think in every case Dan's book
Boardwalk Empire and art film it's the
understanding that prohibition reveals a
lot more this is the story of single
issue political campaigns that
metastasize with the most horrible
unintended consequences including
creating organized crime which we
wouldn't have this is about you know the
demonization of recent immigrants this
is about a whole group of people who
feel like they've lost control of their
country and want to reassert that
control by imposing on these newcomers
some new law it sounds so familiar with
today it resonates with today's themes
what are the parallels with today I mean
is the parallel directly to the drug war
no I think it's less to that I mean
alcohol is used by every culture since
there have been human beings drugs are a
sub cultural thing alcohol was something
everybody did so eliminating it required
a great act of faith to take place drugs
are not favored by a majority of people
and so well there are lots of
similarities and the possibility of
taxing and regulating marijuana is a
hugely interesting consideration once
again it's unintended consequences you
have to be careful I just think it's so
much like our political moment lack of
civil discourse the demonization of
immigrants you know smear campaigns
during presidential elections all of
this sort of
single-issue campaigning or all of that
stuff resonates with today because in
fact human nature is the same and
prohibition brings out and reveals to us
our essential dichotomy not between us
as much as within us that you know that
the generosity and the greed the
tyrannous and the perience the you know
the the sincerity and the hypocrisy the
Saturday night at the bar and the Sunday
morning in church and so that's always
been America's torn on that tension your
previous documentary was about national
America's national parks which called
America's best idea would you say
prohibition was or worse it's close to
being our worst this is the slavery was
our worst idea I'm not sure I'd put
prohibition ii but it's really up there
we for the first time in our history had
an amendment which were usually about
expanding human rights that actually
restricted human rights its was put in
there ironically as an amendment because
that would thought it being enshrined in
the Constitution and therefore never be
repealed but of course it's the only an
amendment that's been repealed which
shows that at least we have some
intelligence and woke up to the
hypocrisy and one of the themes of the
documentary is that actually is what is
also one of political overreach that by
actually trying to make it an amendment
it forced the issue in a way perhaps
that it wouldn't have been I'm not sure
it's overreach as much as its sort of
moral certainty that that the drys were
so certain that they were right so
self-righteous in their convictions that
when they were able to achieve through
uncomplete lee fascinating political
transformation of the country over the
previous hundred years they then refused
to compromise an inch and as it was
clear that the law was in effectively
written that it was clearly and
effectively applied and uneven and
hypocritical
they didn't make adjustments and because
they didn't make adjustments which might
have at least prolonged prohibition for
them it then became just as easy to have
it undone as it had seemed to have been
created you know a lot of people talk
about prohibition as and and this is
certainly part of your argument
the documentary as the kind of the rural
America small-town America conservative
Protestant America the established
America going against new arrivals and
cities your documentary also complicates
that tape by talking about the role that
progressives played in pushing and
maintaining and forcing prohibition talk
a little bit about that well first of
all you have to start and say alcohol
drunkenness in the 19th century wasn't
is a terrific social problem it is the
obligation of a caring society to try to
figure out what to do so there were lots
of different groups that wanted to do
something about it
progressives as well as conservatives
the single issue anti-saloon League plus
all the other groups that wanted to do
it the International Workers of the
world the Wobblies the radical group and
and the industrialist the Ku Klux Klan
and the n-double-a-cp all of these
people wanted it for various reasons and
I think nobody just ever thought it
through what it would actually meant
they always thought it was prohibition
for somebody else and when they woke up
and found that the law used to
administer the amendment the Volstead
Act was draconian in the extreme and
that it had essentially invited
organized crime then I think we were on
the road to disaster and it would took
us nearly fourteen years to undo that
disaster one of the main voices in the
documentary is Pete Hamill the New York
columnist and writer he talks at the end
at the very end of the documentary
actually about how one of the lessons of
prohibition is the folly of trying to
control people's behavior legislatively
prescriptively never underestimate the
need for young dopes to defy the
conventional laws you want something you
want them to brush their teeth make it
illegal make toothpaste ugly
and they'll be standing on the roof
brushing away it's natural to human
beings I think it's a it's a healthy
what are the ways or what are the
behaviors now if you if you pull that
impulse forward that social
conservatives on the one hand are trying
to control and progressives and is there
a straight line to draw through oh
there's a definitely a straight line
through all of these panaceas these
magic bullets these these things that we
can do that will make us a more perfect
society and I think actually one of the
benefits of prohibition despite this
horrible inheritance of organized crime
and all the other bad things it did is
that it gives us pause when somebody
comes and said you know what we need is
we need this amendment or we need that
amendment we just kind of go wait a
second because the memory of prohibition
and those unintended consequences are
fresh and so there are many many things
that you see within politics don't we
also live I mean we're speaking in New
York City that in 2003 banned smoking in
bars and now more recently earlier this
year banded in outdoor spaces we live in
a world where children what is allowed
for children is being more and more
prescribed or we just kind of taking on
different targets that to our mind and
our time seem fine without understanding
you know certainly 800,000 people are
arrested for marijuana possession a year
I mean have we substantially changed no
I think we're always in pursuit of a
more perfect union
and sometimes that pursuit involves
trying to legislate activity I won't
even say morality its activity you know
we we legislate murder we just we don't
steal we we're not into pedophilia so
we're always in the business governments
are and laws are in in in the business
of legislating morality
sometimes we overextend from the left
and from the right and we find people
generally do the right kind of centering
to put us back when you find out that
say cigarette smoke has you brought up
secondhand smoke is dangerous then I
think you've got some scientific
evidence and perhaps it might be seeming
to those people who like to smoke some
in position but I also know someone who
died of lung
sir never smoked a day in their life but
seemed to have delivered developed it
from his parents who were you know
smokers and he was exposed to all his
life to secondhand smoke so maybe that's
a good thing I don't know what the
overreach is but to enshrine something
in the Constitution to make it amendment
that's a different thing
how did you've touched a little bit on
this but how did prohibition fail and
and more importantly I guess what were
the political activities that helped
pull it out of the Constitution and end
it well you know first of all it failed
in its application it was so unevenly
and so unfairly applied it was mostly
working people who were the victims of
it the rich seemed to go away you know
the president of the united states
warren g harding for prohibition
nevertheless had a whiskey cabinet that
met every week fueled by a bootlegger
who brought in a whiskey to the White
House it's bound to fail when you have
that kind of top-to-bottom systemic
hypocrisy the cop on the streaky his
bribed their prohibition agent is bribed
the sergeant at the desk is bribe his
captain is bribed the judges are bribed
the Senators are bribed the assistant
attorney generals are bribe this is a
correct wait are you talking about now
or prohibition I'm talking about
prohibition so I think what happens is
that you see in 1928 eight years into
this that the presidential candidate the
first person who dared speak up Al Smith
a Catholic which was already two or
three or five or ten strikes against him
but also a wet gets destroyed for both
his Catholicism and and his wet posture
but it opens the door and people start
talking about it and and people begin to
realize how hypocritical this whole
thing had been and and the movement
happens the real turning point is the
depression you say okay we got rid of
the fifth largest industry for what
reason we don't have these jobs that we
could use for what reason and we don't
benefit from this tax revenue for what
reason and I think just the sense that
life was so hard in the depression we
can't even appreciate it now even in
tough economic times how bad it was in
the depression
it just seemed when Roosevelt came in
within a week beer was beer was legal
and
the repeal of the amendment which went
into effect that is to say alcohol was
available on December 5th 1933 was
almost anticlimactic which is like we
got to get going with something else
more important and kind of micromanaging
people's lives that if 10% of the
population whatever it is that has a
problem with alcohol let's try to deal
with that but let's not superimpose the
solution on 100% of the people do you
think it's an echo of that but in
today's marijuana legalization movement
so I mean it seems to be tracking a lot
of what was going on in prohibition in
the sense that there are X and now
exceptions for medical marijuana as
there were for medical applications you
see the need for new revenue you see it
normalizing or a mainstreaming of
marijuana
NBA players love it rap stars love it
every you know everybody smokes it or a
smoked it we need revenue things like
that do you see I'm pushing forward yeah
I think it will be incremental and I
think one of the things marijuana as we
know is the biggest cash crop in the
United States more than soybeans more
than wheat more than corn all without
subsidy and except the subsidy of the
black mark exactly and so you have that
attractive sort of thought that that
states have cash-strapped States and
cash-strapped federal government that
it's regulation and it's taxation would
help in the organized crime the criminal
aspect of it but also to bring in
revenues but you also still have to
consider what are the unintended
consequences some kid asked me I've been
traveling around the country it's a kid
asked me he says well how would you test
for driving while under the influence of
marijuana I mean we now administer and
every cop is competent and administering
a breathalyzer test but are you gonna
take a blood sample and and determine
the level of THC to say this guy has no
alcohol in his blood but he's driving
around what do you do that how do we
regulate how old are you to have access
to it what what what are the some of the
questions these are only the superficial
things not knowing what that would do
and I think people because it is drugs
and that you don't have that widespread
human history that you have with alcohol
we've been fermenting brewing and
distilling since there have been human
what will happen it remains to be seen
but you do feel that there's been
incremental difference I grew up in Ann
Arbor Michigan where in the late 60s we
had a $5 pot thing it was like but you
know the meter running out the cop cost
you caught you with less than an ounce
and it was a $5 ticket I mean that was
like parking too long in a parking and
we seem to be coming back more to
something